Good morning.
All right.
Today we are going to take a
fresh look at some of the stuff
we covered in the last two
lectures.
And the graph I want you to
keep in mind as we go through
this lecture in terms of what to
expect.
This was time.
And last Tuesday's lecture we
covered some stuff.
I talked about a method for the
sinusoidal response which was
agony, I warned you it will be
agony, and then towards the end
I showed you another method that
was quite a bit easier but still
pretty hard.
And I promised you that today
there will be a new method which
is going to be so easy ,
actually almost trite.
Just imagine.
I am going to make a statement
right now that I think you will
all find hard to believe.
What I am going to say is just
imagine your RLC circuit,
your resistor,
inductor and capacitor,
a parallel form or series form.
Imagine that you could write
down the characteristic equation
for that by observation in 30
seconds or less.
Just imagine that.
By observation,
boom, write down the
characteristic equation for
virtually any RLC circuit or RC
circuit or whatever.
And we all know that once you
have the characteristic equation
you could very easily go from
there to the time domain
response intuitively or to the
sinusoidal steady-state
response, too.
So just keep that thought in
mind.
Imagine 30 seconds.
And that is what you should
expect in today's lecture.
Students often ask me,
if this stuff is actually so
easy why do you take us through
this tortuous path?
Are we just mean?
Do we just want you show you
how hard things are and then
show the easy way?
I have argued with myself every
year as to whether to just go
ahead and give the easy path and
that's it.
But I think the reason we cover
the basic foundations is that it
gives you a level of insight
that you would not have
otherwise gotten if I directly
jumped into the easy method.
So you need to understand the
foundations and you need to have
seen that at least once.
And second, once you do
something the hard way,
you appreciate all the more the
easy method.
All right.
Today we cover what is called
"The Impedance Model".
First let me do a review just
because of the large amount of
content in the last two
lectures.
I did them using view graphs.
I usually don't like to do
that, but even then it was quite
rushed.
So let me quickly summarize for
you kind of the main points.
We have been looking at,
on Tuesday, the sinusoidal --
--looking at the sinusoidal
steady state response.
Also fondly denoted as SSS.
And the readings for this were
Chapters 14.1 and 14.2.
what we said was if you took
this example circuit and we fed
as input cosine of omega t,
we have an R and a C,
and let's say we cared about
the output response and we cared
about the capacitor voltage.
What we talked about was
focused on the sinusoidal
steady-state response.
And what that meant was first
of all focus on steady-state.
In other words,
just to capture the
steady-state behavior when t
goes to infinity after a long
period of time.
And for most of the circuits
that we consider,
because of the R or presence of
any resistance,
the homogenous response usually
would die out because the
homogenous response is usually
of the form minus t by tau.
And as t goes to infinity this
term tends to go to zero.
We are just looking at the
steady-state.
And therefore,
because of the circuits we
looked at, we can ignore the
homogenous response.
All we are left to do is to
find the particular response to
sinusoids of this form.
And second was focus on
sinusoids.
We said the reason for this was
that, let's say we did not care
particularly
What happened when I just
turned on my amplifier.
I just turned on my amplifier,
often times you see some
distorted sound coming out for a
few seconds and then hear a much
clearer sound.
And that initial part is due to
the transient response.
And let's say we don't care
about that.
We care about the steady state.
Second we focus on sinusoids
because based on the Fourier
series experience that you had
previously, we can represent
repeated signals as a sum of
sines.
And therefore it is important
to understand the behavior of
these circuits when the input is
a sinusoid.
And what was important was this
introduced a new way of looking
at circuits, and that was the
frequency viewpoint.
When we looked at transient
responses, we plotted response
as a function of time.
And when we look at sinusoidal
steady-state,
it becomes interesting to plot
the response as a function of
the frequency,
a function of omega.
What I will do is draw a little
chart for you to sort of
visualize the various processes
we have been going through.
We can liken obtaining the
sinusoidal steady-state response
to following these steps.
Here is my input.
What I did as a first step was
fed my input to a usual circuit
model.
My elements were lumped
elements, built the circuit and
wrote down the VI relationship
for the element.
As a second step I set up the
differential equation.
This was the first of four
steps, set up a differential
equation.
And then the path that I took
first was fraught with real
nightmarish trig.
By the end of the day it would
still yield an answer.
It could be a nightmare.
But I would get something
cosine omega t plus something,
some phase.
I could grunge through the
trig.
And I gave up halfway in class
here, but you could grunge
through it if you would like.
And you would get the answer to
be some sinusoid with some
amplitude and some phase.
So Vi cosine omega t would
produce the response that was
something cosine omega t plus
some phase.
We said this was too painful so
let's punt this.
Instead, what we said we would
do is take a detour,
take an easier path.
And the easier path looked like
this.
I said let's sneak in --
-- Vie^(j omega t) drive.
That is just imagine,
do the math as if you had fed
in not a Vi cosine omega t but a
Vie^(j omega t).
And from Euler's relation you
know that the real part is Vi
cosine omega t.
So we said that I am going to
sneak in this thing,
find the response and just take
the real part of that because
the real part of the input gives
me this.
So this is my "sneaky path".
And what I did there,
as soon as we fed in the e^(j
omega t), because of the
property of exponentials,
the e^(j omega t) cancelled out
in my equation.
And what was left was some
fairly simple complex algebra.
And at the end of the day,
after I grunged through some
fairly simple complex algebra,
I ended up with some response
that looked like this.
Vpe^(j omega t).
What I would find is that for
the input Vie^(j omega t),
I would get a response Vpe^(j
omega t).
And then what I said we would
do is take the real part.
Why take the real part?
Because this is a fake,
a sneaky input.
The input I really care about
is the real part of the sneaky
input.
So this is my sneaky output.
And what I care about is the
real part of the sneaky output.
That is sort of the inverse
superposition argument that I
made on Tuesday that if what I
care about is the real part of
this input, then I just take the
real part and get the output
that I care about.
So I take the real part.
Notice that Vp here,
in the examples we did,
we did an RC example.
The Vp here was a complex
number.
So I could represent that
complex number as,
in many ways.
This is e^(j omega t).
I could represent Vp in an
amplitude, as a phasor,
actually polar coordinates.
I can say that the equivalent
to Vpe to the j angle Vp.
Vp is a complex number.
If you look at the complex
appendix in your course notes,
I can represent a complex
number as an amplitude
multiplied by e raised to j
times some phase.
It's simple complex algebra.
And then what I could do here
is take the real part of that.
And when I took the real part
of that what came about was that
this was simply Vp.
Notice that the angle Vp goes
in here so it becomes j times
omega t plus angle Vp.
It is Vp amplitude times e
raised to j omega t plus j angle
Vp.
And the real part of that is
simply Vp cosine of that stuff.
What I end up getting here is
Vp cosine omega t plus Vp.
The cool thing to notice was
that once I found out this
response here,
I could immediately write down
the output based on Vp.
In other words,
once I had Vp,
I could stop right there in my
math.
I got Vp very quickly here.
This step produced Vp very
quickly, after two algebraic
steps.
And then from here I could
directly write down the answer
as homogenous of Vp cosine omega
t plus angle Vp.
Boom, right there.
So this was a much shorter
path.
And here I just described to
you how this yields an
expression for Vp and angle Vp.
And for our example Vp was
1/(1+j omega RC).
And we often times write a
shorthand notation 1+sRC,
where S is simply j omega.
We commonly jump back and forth
between the shorthand notation S
and j omega.
S has some other fundamental,
has another fundamental
significance you will learn
about in future courses,
but for now S is simply a short
form for j omega.
This was the path that we took.
There is a hard path and an
easier path.
Today I am going to claim that
even this was too hard.
There is an even easier path.
And today what I am going to
show you is that from here we
are going to take one step and
get here.
I am going to show you today
that we won't do this,
we won't do this,
not this, not this,
none of this.
One step and then we are going
to get the answer.
So let's do that.
Before we jump into the
impedance method and get into
doing that, I just would like to
plot for you this function here
just so we can understand a
little bit better exactly what
is going on.
As I mentioned to you,
the output vO for our circuit
there was simply Vp cosine of
omega T plus angle Vp.
Oh, that's Vp so this one
should be Vi here.
I am showing you Vp so there is
a Vi in there.
Vp/Vi=1/(1+j omega RC).
This is a complex number,
and it is simply a number that
when multiplied with Vi gives me
the output.
This is also called a transfer
function and represented as H(j
omega).
This guy is a transfer
function, much like the gain of
my amplifier.
Which when multiplied by the
input to get me the output.
This guy is a complex
multiplier which when multiplied
by Vi gives me Vp.
And as such we call it a
transfer function H(j omega).
And we can plot this function.
Notice that this a function of
omega.
Remember we are taking the
frequency domain view,
so where has time vanished?
Remember that we are taking the
steady state view.
So we are saying in the steady
state, if I wait long enough
this is how my circuit is going
to behave, this is how a circuit
is going to behave.
And the transient responses
have died away and I have time
in my output here so my output
is a cosine.
But that in itself is not very
interesting.
It is a cosine of some
amplitude and has some phase.
What we will plot is we are
going to plot this property
here, Vp as a function of the
frequency.
Vp is frequency dependent.
As an example,
I could plot the absolute value
of Vp/Vi, the modulus of that
versus omega.
And notice that when omega is
zero again intuitive ways of
plotting this is to look at the
value at zero and look at the
value at large omega.
For small omega,
omega goes to zero this is one,
so it starts off here.
And when omega is very large
then it is much bigger than one
here, so this goes down.
Far away this one looks like
1/omega RC.
And this function,
assuming I have linear scales
on my X and Y axes looks like
this.
We also commonly plot this
using log-log scales.
And when you do log-log scales
you get a straight line here,
and then you actually get a
straight line of slope minus one
because the log of this gives
you a line with a constant
slope, it's a slope of negative
one so it becomes a straight
line going down.
The other interesting thing to
realize is that this magnitude
is simply one by one plus omega
squared R squared C squared,
the square root of this.
That's the magnitude here.
And notice when omega equals
1/RC, this thing,
the denominator becomes one by
square root of 2.
Somewhere here when omega
equals 1/RC
The output is one by square
root 2 times the input.
It's an interesting point.
And this is called the "break
frequency".
You can view it as a frequency
where I am getting this
transition from one to a lower
value, and it is where the
output is one by square root two
times the value of the input.
Now you can think back on the
demo we showed you earlier.
And in the demo remember that
as I increased the frequency of
my input sinusoid my output kept
becoming smaller and smaller and
smaller.
And you notice that you can see
this dying out or decaying of
the amplitude as I increase my
omega.
Let me go back.
What you have done is that,
we're going to apply a bunch of
sinusoids to the same circuit
and plot the frequency response,
the ratio of the output versus
input as a function of
frequency.
And kept applying a variety of
frequencies.
So you can listen to the
frequencies as they go by,
and we will plot the amplitude
up on the screen for you.
Just for fun we are going to
play frequencies between,
say, 10 hertz and 20 kilohertz.
It will be fun for you to
figure out at what point you
stop hearing the frequencies.
We are going to play from 10
hertz to 20 kilohertz.
And figure out where your ears
cut out.
That will tell you what the
break frequency of your ear is.
You can see the amplitude being
articulated.
The bottom figure is the phase.
This is the frequency axis.
This is the amplitude,
log-log scales.
I am not sure about you but I
cannot hear anymore.
If you bring your canine
friends to class it is quite
possible that they would go
berserk somewhere here.
As I promised you,
when I plot this on a log-log
scale I get a straight line here
and a straight line out there as
well and the bottom line gives
you the phase.
Now, what you can also do is
you can also go to Websim.
Websim is now linked on your
course homepage.
You can go to Websim and you
can play with various L and C
and R values.
And if you plot frequency
response, if you click on the
frequency response button,
boom, it will give you
frequency responses for your
circuit that look exactly like
that.
You can go and play around with
Thank you.
All right.
As the next step I promised to
show you an easier path.
And let's build some insight.
Is there a simpler way to get
where we would like to get?
In particular,
is there a simpler way to get
Vp?
Let's focus on Vp.
Why Vp?
Because remember Vp was the
complex amplitude of e to the j
omega t.
And once I know Vp then I know
this expression here.
Also notice that this here,
the denominator is simply the
characteristic equation for,
I wonder how many of you
noticed it, is simply the
characteristic equation for the
RC circuit.
If I can write down Vp,
I can write down the
characteristic equation,
it will be in the denominator.
I can also write down the
frequency response very easily
by taking the magnitude and
phase of Vp.
So Vp has all the information
humankind needs for those
circuits.
Is there a simpler way to get
Vp?
To bring some insight,
let's go ahead and write down
--
Let's stare at this for a while
longer and see if light bulbs go
off in our minds.
Of course, I could write this
as Vi/(1+sRC).
I just replaced the shorthand
notation for a j omega.
And I simply divide by SC
throughout.
So I get Vi times,
I simply divide by SC
throughout.
Here is Vi.
I have one by SC,
one by SC plus R.
Light bulbs beginning to go
off?
The form we have here is 1/SC,
some function of my capacitance
divided by something connected
to my capacitance plus R.
This is Vi multiplied by
something connected to
capacitance divided by something
connected to capacitance plus R.
And remember your circuit.
What is that reminiscent of?
What does that remind you of?
Voltage divider?
Hmm.
There is some voltage divider
thing going on here.
I just cannot quite pin it.
It is something about the
capacitor, capacitor plus
booster, some voltage divider
thingamajig happening here.
We will try to figure that out.
What I will do is replace those
terms with something called Zc.
Zc plus Zr.
If I can find out the Zr and Zc
somehow, I can write down the Vp
by inspection by the voltage
divider action,
by some generalization of the
good old Ohm's law that I know
about.
Let's proceed further and see
if we can make some kind of a
connection between this and
this.
If I can make the connection
then boom, I'm done.
I will just use voltage
dividers and I am home.
OK, so let's play around and
see.
There is something in there.
By now you should know that we
are very close.
There is something going on in
there.
I just need to get that spark.
I just need to make that spark
so I can bridge the gap between
something that is really easy
versus where I am.
Let's take a look at the
resistor.
I have my resistor with the
voltage vR across it and a
current iR.
Remember to get to any sort of
steady state you are going to be
dealing with the drives of the
form vI e to the j omega t,
exponential drives.
And by taking the real part,
I know I get the input,
and the real part of the output
gives me the actual output.
Let's say my iR is simply
Ire^st and my vR is Vre^st.
The S is, again,
a shorthand notation for j
omega.
If my current Ire^st of the
exponential form shown there and
here is Vr, I need to find out
what relates Vr and Ir for the
element relationship for the
resistor to hold.
In general, Ir and Vr are
complex numbers.
For the resistor,
I know that Vr=RIr.
And I substitute using my
complex drives here.
So it is Vre^st=RIre^st.
I am just substituting for
these drives,
Ohm's law should apply,
and I cancel off e^st.
And so I get Vr=RIr.
Interesting.
For the resistor I find that,
based on the fundamental
principles of resistor action,
the complex amplitude of the
voltage simply relates to the
complex amplitude of the input
by the proportionality factor R.
In other words,
for the resistor --
Just as the time domain V and I
were related by the
proportionality constant R,
the complex amplitudes Vr and
Ir are also related in the same
way.
That's interesting.
Now let's look at the
capacitor.
Some current ic flowing through
it and a voltage vc.
Let's say the current is Ice^st
and the voltage is Vce^st.
Let's plug these into the
element law for the capacitor
and see if we can find out a way
of relating vc and ic.
I know that ic is simply
Cdvc/dt.
So I replace this with
Ice^st=Cd/dt(vce^st),
which is simply
Ice^st=CsVce^st.
So I can cancel this out again.
Interesting.
Ic=CsVc.
Very interesting.
What is interesting here?
Notice that in the time domain
Ic=Cdvc/dt, the element law for
the capacitor.
So I said let's use exponential
drives, Ice^st,
Vce^st, that's an exponential
drive, and try to find out what
the relationship between the
complex amplitudes are.
I plug them and what do I find?
I find that if my input is
Vce^st, and Vc is the amplitude
of the input,
then the current is simply
given by something multiplied
Vc.
It's very similar in form to
what I saw here.
The resistor,
Vr=RIr.
For the capacitor,
Vc=Ic/sc.
1/sc kind of plays the role of
R.
In other words,
the complex amplitudes around
the capacitor are related by Vc
equals some constant times Ic.
Almost like a funny Ohm's law
kind of relationship where Vc
and IC are complex amplitudes.
For the inductor it is the same
way, iL, vL and L.
Let's say iL=Ile^st and
vL=Vle^st.
Substitute the values for the
inductor into its element
relationship as well.
I know that vL=LdiL/dt.
Therefore, substituting the
complex amplitudes is L.
And diL/dt will simply be
Ilse^st.
So I cancel out the
exponentials.
The reason we're able to do all
of this is simply the remarkable
beauty of exponentials.
Exponentials are absolutely
stunningly beautiful.
The reason is that when I
differentiate them what I get
back is the exponential times
some constant,
and the constant was in its
numerator multiplying t.
And that's the beauty of
exponentials.
If this was a sine then I would
get cosine and a sine.
With exponentials these cancel
out and what I am left with is
something that is LsIl.
Again, for the inductor,
the voltage across the inductor
relates to some constant Ls here
times Il.
This is absolutely stunning and
almost looks like a form of
Ohm's law here.
What I am going to do is let's
give this the name Zr.
Let's give this 1/sC the name
Zc.
And let's give this the name
ZL.
It kind of behaves like a
resistor, so the resistor simply
becomes Zr.
And 1/sC behaved like a
resistor so I called it Zc.
And this is a ZL.
These are called "impedances".
In other words,
for a capacitor,
as far as complex inputs and
outputs are concerned,
if Vc and Ic is fed to it,
the capacitor can be replaced
by an impedance Zc where I can
write the relationship between
Vc and Ic as Vc=ZcIc.
Where Zc is simply one by sc.
Similarly, for an inductor --
-- I can write its impedance ZL
as sL and I get Vl=ZLIl.
And finally for a resistor it
is pretty simple.
What I am saying is that if I
am in the region of the
playground, if I constrain
myself in the region of the
playground where my inputs are
something Vi e to the j omega t
or exponentials,
in that little region of the
playground now,
I am focusing more and more on
small parts of the playground so
I am kind of boxed in right now.
In that region of the
playground this applies.
playground, I can replace
resistors by impedances,
capacitors with impedances of
value 1/sC.
And within that playground the
beauty of analysis there is that
in that region of the playground
where the inputs are of the form
Vie^st, it turns out that the
element laws are simply
generalizations of Ohm's law.
That is absolutely stunning.
It is one of the biggest
hallelujah moments in learning
circuits.
This is really big.
And I think this is almost as
big as the realization that you
can take a nonlinear circuit,
operate it at a given operating
point, and you can sit around
doing Zen things,
looking at small perturbations
in there, those are going to be
linearly related.
This is one of the big
hallelujah moments in 6.002.
And this is of the same
magnitude as the small signal
response being linear.
It is something that is
completely non-intuitive.
It is something that you just
would not have known until you
had seen it happen.
The same way here.
This is very important so I
will repeat it again.
I have boxed myself into this
small region of the playground
where all I care about are
sinusoidal inputs and
steady-state responses.
So there I focus on complex
inputs, Vi e to the j omega t.
And I have just shown you that
I can replace inductors,
capacitors, resistors with
their impedances.
And the amplitudes of the
corresponding signals around
them are related by just a
simple Ohm's law like
relationship using impedances.
I am sort of boxed into this
playground, right?
In my playground it is all
about e to the ij omega t.
e to the ij omega t is implicit
everywhere.
I just don't show it.
If I want to talk to somebody
else outside but within MIT in
this small region,
it's all e to the ij omega t in
there.
If I want to talk to somebody
outside, get out of MIT,
get out of this playground,
what else do I have to do?
I have to take the real part.
Don't forget that.
Remember that,
take for example Vc here,
so Vc is this,
so implicit in all of this is
that if I measure Vc at some
place it is really going to be
Vce to the j omega t.
And if we the cosine,
the real part,
then I have to take a real part
of this.
And the real part of that would
Vc cosine of omega t angle Vc.
This piece here kind of goes
unsaid.
We will agree that we have to
do it, but we just skip that
step because it is obvious.
We just deal with Vcs and Vls
now.
So a new notation certainly
sneaked by you,
and that notation looks like a
big letter and a small letter.
Remember you have seen vL,
this is the total behavior,
you have seen vl,
that's a small signal behavior,
and now you see this,
Vl, capital V small l.
And we also have DC,
we have labeled operating point
values as VL,
capital V, capital L.
We have one thing left so
nobody go out there inventing
something new because we would
be in trouble.
This is capital V,
small l, and this is simply
"complex amplitude" in the small
boxed region of my playground
where good things happen and
exponentials fly.
Whenever someone gives you a
variable, capital V,
small l, remember it's a
complex amplitude,
a complex number,
and you know how to get to the
time domain from there.
You take that number,
take the real part,
multiple the number by e to the
j omega t and take the real
part, which is tantamount to
magnitude cosine omega t plus
angle of that number.
Actually, you know what?
Let's send this up.
Back to an example.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
This is not good.
This is my time domain circuit.
Remember this was my time
domain circuit.
A vI input.
A vC output.
I wanted to analyze this.
What I am telling you now is
let's box ourselves in this
impedance playground.
And in the impedance playground
the input becomes the complex
amplitude of the input,
my resistance gets replaced by
a box Zr, my capacitor gets
replaced by a box Zc.
And the voltage I care about
here is Vc.
Zr = R and Zc=1/sC.
Now, there we go.
I can write down Vc using a
voltage divider action as Vc is
simply Zc/(Zc+Zr),
done, times Vi of course.
And that gives me 1/sC divided
by 1/sC+R and multiplying
throughout by sC I get 1/1+sCR
where S is j omega.
Just cannot get any simpler.
How long did I take to do this?
30 seconds.
Where I spent a whole lecture
on Tuesday grinding through
first trig, giving up halfway
and collapsing,
and then showing you the sneaky
path which was still pretty
painful, but 30 seconds,
boom.
This stuff is spectacularly
beautiful.
The really cool thing here is
that in this impedance domain
for linear circuits all your
good old tricks apply.
Your Thevenin,
your Norton,
your superposition,
name it and it applies for this
linear circuit.
If you close your eyes and make
believe that Zr is like an R and
simply apply all the techniques
you have learned so far in this
linear playground.
Just a little hack at the end
where this is the complex
amplitude.
And if you want to go to the
time domain part then you do the
usual thing.
Modulus Vc cosine omega t plus
angle Vc.
Just remember that.
That's the jump to get back to
the time domain.
Just to show you that this not
just works for one little
rinky-dink circuit here,
let me take a more complicated
circuit.
If I believe in my own BS,
I should be able to apply this
theory to my series RLC,
the big painful circuit that we
did differential equations for
about a week ago.
Let's do it.
I have an inductor,
a capacitor and a resistor.
What I am going to do is
replace this with the impedance
model.
Input Vi.
Let's say this was vI.
Let's say I cared about vR.
L, C and R.
The impedance model would
simply be Vi.
What's the impedance of an
inductor?
SL.
And for the capacitor it is
1/sC.
And for a resistor it is simply
R.
And just remember,
if I can find out VR then for
an input cosine of the form Vi
cosine omega t the output will
given by |Vr| cosine of omega t
plus angle Vr.
Just remember this last step.
But Vr itself is trivially
determined.
It is the voltage divider
action again times Vi.
And the voltage divider action
is in the denominator I sum
these thingamajigs,
so ZL+ZC+ZR,
ZR in the numerator.
And Zr is simply R.
ZL is sL.
Zc is 1/sC.
And R is R.
Vi.
And I multiply through by,
in this particular situation,
by s/L.
I want to get it into the same
form as you've seen before.
Multiply throughout,
the numerator and denominator
by s/L, what do I get?
I get RS/L and out here I end
up getting S squared plus 1/LC,
and I get plus R/L S.
I am done.
Look at that.
Well, a little more than 30
seconds.
Maybe a minute.
What is this?
Where have you seen this
before?
The denominator of this
expression here?
Ah, characteristic equation for
the RLC.
Remember I promised you in the
beginning that when we come to
the end of the day using a
simple one-minute expression I
am going to write down the
characteristic equation?
Boom, here is what I get.
Did somebody hear an echo in
there?
Notice that just by doing a
simple voltage divider
thingamajig, I got this
expression.
And now I can write down the
frequency response by replacing
s is equal to j omega.
Even more beautiful and what is
even more stunningly pretty here
is that remember the intuitive
method I taught you about?
The characteristic equation
gives you alpha,
omega nought,
omega d and Q.
And based on those we can
sketch even the time domain
response.
Guess what?
RLC circuits are passÈ now.
You can just write this thing
down and you're done,
30 seconds or less.
No DEs, no trig,
no nothing.
OK.